INSTEAD OF TUESDAY.
SO MARK YOUR CALENDARS.
BIG GAME TONIGHT.
WARRIORS TAKING ON THE BUCKS AND
KLAY HAS RETURNED.
LIV, DID YOU WATCH HIS FIRST
GAME WEEKS.
LOVING WHAT I'M SEEING SO FAR.
>> YES, LOVING WHAT I SEE SO
FAR.
WARRIORS FANS ARE EXCITED.
CAN'T WAIT TO GET DRAYMOND BACK.
WE ARE GIVING OUTLY.
RIGHT NOW, LIV, I'M NOT ON THE
HANDY DANDY iPAD TODAY.
I HAVE THE PHONE OUT.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS LOOKING FOR
TAKES.
I'M LOOKING FOR GOOD TAKES.
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY YOU GET
HOODIES.HEY'RE STAKING ABOUT
KLAY.
THAT IS ROB GOOCHIE 2X4.
THE PROUDUCER JUST SAID GIVE AWY
A JERSEY.
INDERMAN HAS THE FLINT TROPICS
JERSEY ON.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
ARE YOU READY TO GET THIS SHOW
OFFICIALLY STARTED?
>> I'M READY TO GO.
>> LET'S GET IT STARTED.
IT'S TNT BASKETBALL THURSDAY.
FANDUEL IS BOOSTING THE 3x2 IN
NOT ONE BY BOTH GAMES TONIGHT.
THE QUESTION IS WILL THERE BE
TWO THREE-POINTERS IN THE FIRST
THREE MINUTES OF THE GAME?
LAST WEEK THE 3x2 IN THE
CELTICS/KNICKS GAME, IT CASHED.
LET'S LOOK.
>> SURE DID.
>> THERE IT IS.
THAT'S 48 FROM THE TOP.
YES, SIR.
GREEN DOT LIKE THEY DO ON 2K.
THAT'S ANOTHER ONE.
>> HE WAS PLAYING OUT OF HIS
MIND IN THAT GAME.
>> HE DEFINITELY WAS.
TODAY WE ASKED YOU GUYS ON
TWITTER, WHICH 3x2 WILL CASH
TONIGHT?
IS IT THE CARRY YOURS TAKING ON
THE MILWAUKEE BUCKS OR PORTLAND
TAKING ON THE DENVER NUGGETS?
HERE ARE THE RESULTS.
THERE IT IS.
I'M NOT SURPRISED BY THAT, LIV.
WE KNOW WHO IS PLAYING GOLDEN
STATE.
THE SPLASH BROTHERS ARE BACK.
WHAT I NEED YOU TO DO IS GET IN
THE COMMENTS AND TELL US WHICH
3x2 IS A LOCK.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
TALK TO ME, WHICH IS YOUR
FAVORITE?
>> NORMALLY I'M ONE FOR FADING
THE PUBLIC.
TONIGHT I'M RIDING WITH THE
PUBLIC.
DON'T LET THE BANNER FOOL YOU.
I LOVE MY NUGGETS, ABSOLUTELY.
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE TOO
INCONSISTENT AND THE TRAIL
BLAZERS ARE FAR TOO INJURED.
I HAVE TO RIDE WITH THE
HEALTHIER TEAM HERE.
NOT TO MENTION BOTH GOLDEN STATE
AND MILWAUKEE RANK TOP FIVE FOR
THREE-POINTERS ATTEMPTED AND
MADE.
I THINK THIS IS A GOOD
BOUNCE-BACK SPOT FOR STEPH WHO
WAS 2 FOR 9 IN THE LAST GAME
VERSUS THE GRIZZLIES.
I LIKE THIS ONE TO HIT.
I'M RIDING WITH THE PUBLIC.
GIVE ME THE WARRIORS AND THE
BUCKS WITH THE 3x2.
>> I LOVE WHEN TISTICS INTO THE.
I LOVE IT.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
I'M GIVING OUT HOODIES AND
LOOKING FOR TAKES.
TYRELL IS SAYING KLAY IS ABOUT
TO EAT TONIGHT.
HE HAS KLAY EATING THE SANDWICH
AS A GIF.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED IN THE
COMMENTS.
INDERMAN SAYS GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS VERSUS MILWAUKEE.
HE'S RIDING WITH YOU.
ONE MORE IN ME.
ALEX NORTHEAST L.A., THAT'S HIS
USER NAME.
HE SAYS GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS
AND MILWAUKEE.
SO GUESS WHAT, EVERYBODY?
I'M MAKING THE DECISION.
WE ARE RIDING WITH THE GOLDEN
STATE WARRIORS AND THE MILWAUKEE
BUCKS 3x2 TONIGHT.
LET'S GET RICH OFF OF THE 3x2.
HOPEFULLY KLAY AND STEPH CAN
THROW UP SOME THREES AND
HOPEFULLY SOME BUCKS, THEY CAN
THROW UP SOME THREES IN THE
FIRST THREE MINUTES.
AS MENTIONED AT THE TOP OF THE
SHOW, MY MAN, THE OTHER SPLASH
BROTHER, KLAY THOMPSON IS BACK.
TODAY WE ASKED YOU IN THE APP,
HOW MANY POINTS WILL KLAY
THOMPSON SCORE TONIGHT?
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL US
WHAT YOU GUYS THINK.
AT THE END OF THE GAME, WE'LL DM
ONE RANDOM FAN WHO GUESSES
CORRECTLY AND HOOK YOU UP WITH A
PAIR OF THE NEW AIRPOD MAXES.
LET'S LOOK AT THE CURRENT ODDS.
KLAY'S OVER/UNDER IS SITTING AT
14.5.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
ANYTHING ELSE YOU LIKE HERE?
>> I DO LIKE KLAY'S OVER
TONIGHT.
I THINK HE'S A SOLID DUO WITH
STEPH CURRY.
NO DRAYMOND GREEN, SO KLAY IS
FIGURING OUT HIS OFFENSIVE ROLE.
I THINK THEY'LL GET BETTER EVERY
GAME, WHICH I LOVE.
I DO LIKE GIANNIS TO HAVE A BIG
GAME.
HE WON'T BE GUARDED BY DRAYMOND.
HE'S AVERAGED 33 POINTS PER GAME
IN THE LAST FIVE.
WHO IS GUARDING HIM BESIDES
DRAYMOND GREEN?
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY IS CAPABLE
OF GUARDING GIANNIS OUTSIDE OF
DRAYMOND.
HE WILL CARRY THAT OFFENSIVE
LOAD AND HIT 30.5 WITH EASE.
I'M TAKING HIS OVER.
>> LIV IS ROCKING WITH GIANNIS
OVER.
OKAY.
I MENTIONED KLAY OVER/UNDER AT
14.5.
ACTUALLY THE LINE MOVED.
IT'S AT 13.5.
THAT'S EVEN BETTER.
>> THAT'S BETTER.
>> EVEN BETTER.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE KLAY
THOMPSON OVER TONIGHT.
13.5 SHOULD BE EASY.
NO DRAYMOND.
WE WILL BE LEANING ON KLAY TO
SCORE THE BALL.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES FOR
TAKES.
I HAVE THIS ONE SAYS KLAY, HE'S
GOING FOR 16 UPON THE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
DAVE ROSE SAYS KLAY IS GOING FOR
19 POINTS TONIGHT.
SHOUT OUT TO BOTH OF YOU.
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
PLEASE REMEMBER AFTER THE GAME,
WE'RE GOING TO HIT UP ONE PERSON
AND HOOK YOU UP WITH A NEW PAIR
OF AIRPOD MAXES.
IT'S TIME FOR MY FAVORITE PART
OF THE SHOW.
LET'S TALK MAJOR MARKETS, MONEY
LINES AGAINST THE SPREADS AND
POINTS TOTALS FOR TONIGHT'S
GAME.
LET'S LOOK AT THE ODDS.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING HERE?
WHAT DO YOU LIKE?
>> YEAH, I'M REALLY LIKING UNDER
211 IN THAT PORTLAND/DENVER
GAME.
LOTS OF STARTERS OUT FOR THE
TRAIL BLAZERS.
THAT MAKES SCORING FOR THEM
DIFFICULT TONIGHT.
AND THEY ARE ALSO FACING A
DENVER DEFENSE THAT ALLOWS THE
EIGHTH FEWEST POINTS TO
OPPONENTS.
THE NUGGETS ARE RANKED BOTTOM
TEN PER POINTS PER GAME.
52% OF THEIR GAMES HAVE GONE
UNDER.
51% OF DENVER'S GAMES HAVE GONE
SO, WITH SO MANY PLAYERS OUT AND
THE NUGGETS STRUGGLING TO SCORE
BUT STILL KEEPING SOLID DEFENSE,
I'M RIDING WITH UNDER 211 IN
THAT GAME.
>> LIV IS ROCKING WITH THE
UNDER.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HEARD, I GOT
A PHONE CALL.
IT WAS VEGAS CALLING ME AND
LETTING ME KNOW TO TAKE THE
WARRIORS MONEY LINE TONIGHT.
THEY SAID TAKE THE WARRIORS
MONEY LINE TONIGHT.
I'M GOING TO -- THE REASON IS --
REASON IS BECAUSE THE WARRIORS
ONLY LOST TWO TIMES IN A ROW ONE
TIME THIS YEAR.
THEY LOST THE LAST GAME, IT WAS
A HARD-FOUGHT GAME IN MEMPHIS.
I SEE THE BOUNCE BACK TONIGHT.
I SEE THE BOUNCE BACK TONIGHT IN
MILWAUKEE.
>> THEY NEED IT.
>> SO GIVE ME THE WARRIORS.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
I'M IN THE HANDY DANDY iPHONE.
HERE WE GO.
I GOT XAVIER SAYING PORTLAND
WINNING BY 10 TONIGHT.
THAT'S HIS FAVORITE BET.
HERE WE GO.
THIS ONE SAYS 18 EASY FOR KLAY.
HE SAYS KLAY WILL SCORE EASY.
HE'S GOING OVER THAT POINT
TOTAL.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY THAT I
MENTIONED.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
WE TALKED MAJOR MARKETS.
LET'S TALK PLAYER PROPS.
IT'S TIME FOR LOCK OR NOT.
I'LL PUT UP A PROP.
I NEED ALL OF YOU, EVERYBODY IN
THE COMMENTS TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHETHER IT
IS A -- IS IT A LOCK OR NOT?
ARE YOU READY.
>> READY TO GO.
LET'S DO IT.
>> LET'S GET TO IT.
DRAGIC TO SCORE OVER 25 POINTS.
SITTING AT MINUS 114.
THIS IS YOUR NUGGETS.
HE PLAYS FOR YOUR FAVORITE TEAM.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
TALK TO ME.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS A LOCK OR
NOT?
>> OH, YES.
OH, YES.
IT'S A LOCK.
ABSOLUTELY.
RIGHT NOW THE TRAIL BLAZERS GIVE
UP THE THIRD MOST POINTS TO
OPPOSING CENTERS AT 24 POINTS
PER GAME.
JOKIC IS NOT YOUR AVERAGE
CENTER.
HE HAS CARRIED THIS DENVER
OFFENSE ALONGSIDE WILL BARTON
SINCE ALL OF THEIR STARTERS HAVE
BEEN INJURED.
TONIGHT WILL BARTON IS NOT
PLAYING THAT MEANS THE LOAD
FALLS ON JOKIC'S SHOULDERS.
HE AVERAGES 28 AGAINST THE TRAIL
BLAZERS TEAM.
SHOULD BE EASY MONEY TONIGHT.
ABSOLUTELY A LOCK.
>> LIV, YOU MENTIONED WILL
BARTON NOT IN THE LINEUP
TONIGHT.
I THINK THAT'S GOING TO LEAD TO
MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUR BOY
DOWN LOW.
SO I'M ROCKING WITH YOU.
THIS IS YOUR TEAM.
HE IS THE MVP, LIKE YOU SAID.
THE MVP OF YOUR TEAM.
I THINK HE CAN GET 25 TONIGHT.
THIS ONE IS KIND OF DICEY.
BEN McLEMORE TO MAKE FIVE
THREE-POINTERS?
SITTING AT PLUS 160.
I DO NOT LIKE THIS AT ALL.
THAT'S MY TAKE.
LIV, DO YOU LIKE THIS OR DO YOU
NOT?
>> NO.
NO, I REALLY DON'T.
LISTEN, HE HAS BEEN PLAYING
BETTER THAN EARLIER IN THE
SEASON BECAUSE HE IS GETTING
MORE VALUABLE PLAYING TIME, AKA
PUTTING UP MORE THREE-POINT
SHOTS.
HE'S MAKING SOME OF THEM.
I KNOW HE HAD FIVE LAST GAME.
HOWEVER HE'S FACING A DENVER
TEAM WHOSE OPPONENTS HAVE THE
NINTH LOWEST THREE-POINT
PERCENTAGE.
FIVE IS A LOT OF THREES.
HE ONLY HIT THAT OVER IN 1 OF
THE LAST 5.
I DON'T LOVE IT.
I THINK THE VALUE IS PLUS 160
FOR A REASON.
IT'S NOT MY FAVORITE PLAY.
I'LL SAY NOT A LOCK.
>> LIV, I THINK LIKE YOU SAID,
IT'S PLUS 160 FOR A REASON.
I THINK THE ODDS MAKERS THINK
THIS ONE IS NOT A LOCK.
THAT'S WHY IT'S AT PLUS 160.
FINALLY, LET'S MOVE ON TO
NURKIC.
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO NURKIC, I
HAVE TO GET IN THE COMMENTS.
I HAVE TO GET IN THE COMMENTS
AND GIVE MY PEOPLE SOME HOODIES.
THIS IS WHY THEY COME.
I HAVE NORTHEAST L.A. IS BACK IN
THE COMMENTS SAYING FADE BEN
McLEMORE.
SNOOPY 2153 SAYS NAH, CAN'T
TRUST 5.
I CAN'T TRUST BEN McLEMORE
MAKING 5.
BEASTY J6 SAYS NO SHOT BEN STAYS
THAT HOT.
THEY'RE SAYING NO SHOT THAT HE'S
HITTING THOSE FIVE THREES.
THEY'RE AGREEING WITH ME AND
YOU.
FINALLY TO NURKIC TO GRAB 12 OR
MORE REBOUNDS AND SITTING AT
PLUS 190.
THAT'S A LOT OF PLUS MONEY RIGHT
THERE.
A LOT OF PLUS MONEY.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
DO YOU LIKE THIS GOING AGAINST
THE NUGGETS?
>> NO, I REALLY DON'T.
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU, THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE MOMENTS WHERE I MAY
BE BETTING WITH MY HEART A BIT
BECAUSE I HAVE BEEN BURNED BY
NURKIC WAY TOO MANY TIMES.
>> I DO IT ALL THE TIME.
>> IN MY OPINION, HE'S A BETTING
LIABILITY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT VERSION OF HIM
I'LL GET ON ANY NIGHT.
ONE SECOND HE'S A REBOUNDING
MACHINE, THE NEXT MACHINE HE'S
PLAYING SCARED BASKETBALL.
YOU CANNOT PLAY SCARED AGAINST
JOKIC.
HE ONLY AVERAGED 6 1/2 BOARDS
AGAINST DENVER THIS SEASON.
HE HIT THE OVER IN 4 OF THE LAST
5, BUT IT'S A DIFFERENT STORY
WHEN YOU FACE JOKIC.
I WOULD SAY NOT A LOCK TONIGHT.
>> YOU BROUGHT UP A GOOD POINT.
HE'S FACING THE JOKER.
THE JOKER IS ALSO A GOOD
REBOUNDER.
12 REBOUNDS IS HAVING A GAME.
THAT'S HAVING A REAL GOOD GAME
FOR MY GUY NURKIC.
I THINK I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH
YOU.
I THINK I'M GOING TO ROCK RIGHT
THERE WITH YOU AND SAY NO TO THE
12 REBOUNDS TODAY.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
YOU'RE DROPPING LOTS.
INDERMAN SAYS NO LOCK.
NORTHEAST L.A. IS BACK SAYING NO
LOCK.
KILLA KELLS SAYS NOT TODAY.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'VE W
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
THIS ONE SAYS NURKIC MAY GET
THREE OR FIVE REBOUNDS ONLY.
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
IT'S TIME TO BUILD THE B/R
BETTING CUSTOM GAME PARLAY.
LAST WEEK, CELTICS/KNICKS
PARLAY, WE CASHED OVER 400.
WE'LL TRY TO KEEP THE STREAK
GOING.
WE'LL KEEP THE GOOD VIBES GOING
AND SPEAKING OF PARLAYS, THREE
FRIENDS THREW 50 CENTS EACH ON
THIS FIRST BASKET SCORE PARLAY
LAST NIGHT.
THEY TURNED 50 CENTS INTO OVER
130K.
LIV, PER PERSON.
NOT COMBINED, BUT PER PERSON.
I KNOW YOU'RE GOING ON -- I KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TON A VACATION
SOON.
DO YOU AND YOUR FRIENDS EVER GET
TOGETHER AND COME UP WITH
PARLAYS LIKE THIS?
>> I MEAN, I'M SURE WE DO, BUT
THEY DON'T HIT.
YOU KNOW, IT'S ONE OF THOSE
THINGS WHERE YOU COULD THROW A
BUNCH OF THINGS TOGETHER AND YOU
LOVE THAT VALUE, YOU'RE LIKE
COULD YOU IMAGINE?
BUT YOU NEVER ACTUALLY THINK
IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
HERE'S WHERE I HAVE THE MOST
RESPECT FOR THESE GUYS.
FIRST BASKET SCORERS, THERE'S NO
WAY TO HANDICAP THAT.
I DON'T CARE HOW GOOD OF A
HANDICAPPER YOU THINK YOU ARE.
THERE'S NO WAY TO HANDICAP THAT.
THEY WERE JUST ON THE RIGHT SIDE
OF FATE AT THAT POINT.
THEY NEED TO GO NOW APPLY FOR
THE POWERBALL AND THE LOTTERY.
LUCK IS ON THEIR SIDE NOW.
CONGRATS TO THEM.
THAT'S A WHOLE LOT OF MONEY.
I'M IMPRESSED.
>> THAT IS A WHOLE LOT OF MONEY.
WE NEED THOSE GOOD VIBES HERE.
I'M ABOUT TO GIVE OUT OUR
PARLAY.
EVERYBODY GET IN THE COMMENTS
AND TELL ME WHAT YOU THINK.
WHICH LEGS ARE LOCKS.
WHICH LEGS ARE NOT.
TONIGHT WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
WARRIORS TAKING ON THE BUCKS
GAME.
LIV, ARE YOU READY TO GET TO IT?
>> I'M READY TO GO.
>> LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
ALL RIGHT.
FIRST OFF, WE TALKED ABOUT HIM
EARLIER IN THE SHOW.
MY GUY, KLAY THOMPSON.
TO SCORE TWO OR MORE
THREE-POINTERS TONIGHT.
LIV, TALK TO ME NICE, PLEASE.
TALK TO ME NICE.
DO YOU LIKE THIS ONE OR DO YOU
NOT?
>> YEAH, I KNOW I SAID EARLIER
THAT I WAS KIND OF CONCERNED
BECAUSE I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT HIS
OFFENSIVE ROLE WAS QUITE YET ON
THE TEAM.
HERE'S WHAT I DO KNOW.
HE WILL TAKE THE SHOTS.
IN A COMBINED 40 MINUTES OF
PLAYING TIME IN JUST TWO GAMES,
HE HAS HAD 13 THREE-POINT
ATTEMPTS.
HE'S GOING TO TAKE THE SHOT.
IT'S A MATTER OF WHETHER IT
HITS.
HERE'S THE DEAL.
BEING GUARDED BY GRAYSON ALLEN
DOES NOT SCARE ME FOR KLAY AT
ALL.
I LIKE THIS LEG.
HE WILL TAKE THE SHOTS.
HE WILL PIT TWOHIT TWO PLUS.
I LIKE THIS A LOT.
>> WE GOT THE LIV APPROVAL ON
THE KLAY THREE-POINTERS.
NEXT LEG OF THE PARLAY, IT'S MY
GUY, THE OTHER SPLASH BROTHER,
LIV.
STEPH CURRY, 25 PLUS POINTS
TONIGHT.
HE'S BEEN -- I WOULD SAY ON
STEPH CURRY TERMS, HE'S BEEN
SHAKY.
HE HAD A TRIPLE-DOUBLE LAST GAME
AGAINST THE GRIZZLIES, BUT STEPH
HAS HIGH STANDARDS.
HE'S BEEN PLAYING, YOU KNOW, NOT
TO THOSE STANDARDS AS OF LATE.
BUT DO YOU THINK HE CAN GET 25
POINTS TONIGHT?
>> HERE'S HOW I THINK THIS WILL
PLAY OUT.
I THINK WE'LL SWEAT IT OUT.
IT WILL BE HALFTIME.
WE'LL GO OH, I DON'T THINK HE'LL
HIT IT.
HE WILL COME OUT OF THE GATES
HALFTIME AND DO WHAT HE DOES
BEST.
THIS IS A GREAT BOUNCE-BACK SPOT
FOR HIM.
ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT WHEN HE GETS
HOT, THERE'S NO STONIPPING HIM.
HE KNOWS HE'S FACING THE BUCKS.
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD TEAM.
THE WARRIORS NEED ANOTHER WIN
TONIGHT AFTER THEIR LOSS.
I THINK IT'S A GOOD SPOT FOR
HIM.
I THINK HE HITS THIS.
>> I LIKE THAT.
IN ORDER FOR THE WARRIORS TO
WIN, STEPH CURRY HAS TO SCORE 25
POINTS TONIGHT.
TONIGHT HE DOES.
IN RECENT GAMES THE WARRIORS
HAVE BEEN OKAY WITH STEPH NOT
SCORING, BUT TONIGHT, NO
DRAYMOND, STEPH NEEDS TO SCORE
25 IN ORDER FOR THEM TO WIN.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT LEG OF
THE PARLAY.
I KNOW YOU'LL LIKE THIS ONE.
YOU MENTIONED IT EARLIER.
GIANNIS ANTETOKOUNMPO SCORING 30
PLUS TONIGHT.
WE ALREADY KNOW YOU LIKE THIS
ONE, RIGHT?
>> I DO.
>> WE GOT THE LIV APPROVAL.
WE GOT LIV APPROVAL.
THE LAST LEG.
LET'S GO TO THE LAST LEG.
MY GUY, KHRIS MIDDLETON, I HAVE
TO TAKE A DEEP BREATH HERE.
SIX ASSISTS?
CHRKHRIS MIDDLETON?
I KNOW HE'S KIND OF DEVELOPING
INTO A PLAYMAKER LAST YEAR, BUT
DO YOU THINK HE CAN GET SIX
TODAY?
>> YEAH.
HERE'S THE DEAL.
LIKE I SAID EARLIER, THE REASON
I'M ON GIANNIS TONIGHT TAKING
THE OVER ON HIS POINTS, WHO IS
GUARDING HIM TONIGHT?
I DON'T THINK ANYONE IS.
I THINK HE'S KIND OF THE GUY
THAT THE OFFENSE -- THE BALL
NEEDS TO BE IN HIS HANDS AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE.
WHO IS GETTING HIM THE BALL?
KHRIS MIDDLETON.
HE HAS THAT LEADERSHIP TO BE A
FACILITATOR AND TO TRUST GIANNIS
TO PUT THE BALL IN THE NET.
I LIKE KHRIS MIDDLETON TO FEED
THE BALL TO GIANNIS ALL NIGHT
LONG.
DO I THINK WE'LL BE SWEATING IT
OUT?
ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK IT'S A GOOD PLAY.
>> I SEE WHAT YOU DID.
YOU WERE JUST CONNECTING THE
DOTS.
YOU KNOW GIANNIS IS GOING TO
SCORE.
>> I AM.
>> WHO WILL GIVE HIM THE BALL.
KHRIS MIDDLETON.
>> EXACTLY.
>> LIV IS CONNECTING THE DOTS.
HOPEFULLY THIS PARLAY CAN
CONNECT THE DOTS TONIGHT LIKE
LAST WEEK.
LET'S PULL UP THE ODDS AND SEE
WHAT THIS COULD DO IF WE PUT
$100 DOWN.
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
$508.48 IF YOU WERE TO PUT $100
DOWN ON OUR SAME-GAME PARLAY.
BEFORE I GET INTO THE COMMENTS.
WHAT ARE YOU GRADING THE
SAME-GAME PARLAY?
>> ALL RIGHT.
I MEAN, I HAVE PERSONALLY BEEN
ON A LITTLE NBA HEATER MYSELF.
OUR PARLAY CASHED LAST WEEK.
I DO REALLY LIKE THIS PARLAY.
I'LL GIVE IT AN "A" MINUS.
THE ONLY REASON IT'S NOT AN "A"
OR "A" PLUS, YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU FEEL TOO
CONFIDENT IN GAMBLING.
THE BETTING GODS COME DOWN AND
HUMBLE YOU.
WE DON'T NEED THAT TONIGHT.
WE NEED WINNERS ONLY PLEASE, AS
GREG WOULD SAY.
"A" MINUS TO STAY HUMBLE.
BUT I LOVE THE PARLAY.
IT'S STILL UP THERE WITH THE
PASSING GRADE.
OVERACHIEVING STUDENT FOR SURE,
BUT "A" MINUS TO BE SAFE.
>> WE WILL TAKE THAT.
IT'S TIME TO GET INTO THE
COMMENTS.
I'M GVING IVING AWAY A HOODIE A
JERSEY HERE.
I HAVE SPORTS FEED.
HE SAYS KLAY WITH TWO THREES.
PLEASE.
SPORTS FEED, JUST FOR THE VIBES,
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU THE
JERSEY.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
I'M BACK INTO THE COMMENTS, LIV.
I HAVE LANDON FOSS 18, HE SAYS
THEY ALL WILL HIT.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
ONE MORE FOR THE PEOPLE AT HOME.
NOT STEPH CURRY SAYS WARRIORS
ARE GETTING THE DUB TONIGHT.
YOU KNOW I LIKE THAT.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE AS WELL.
THE GRIZZLIES ARE ON A TEN-GAME
WINNING STREAK.
JOHN MORANT MAKING AN MVP RUN.
TELL ME IF YOU THINK THE
GRIZZLIES CAN WIN IT ALL.
IF NOT, TELL ME YOUR LOCKS TO
WIN THE CHAMPIONSHIP.
LET'S LOOK AT THE LATEST ODDS.
NETS AND WARRIORS ARE STILL THE
FAVORITES.
ON THE SECOND PAGE, LIV, THE
SECOND PAGE, WE HAVE THE
GRIZZLIES SITTING AT PLUS 42 00.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT PLAY?
ARE THE GRIZZLIES TITLE
CONTENDERS IN
>> HERE'S WHAT I LOVE ABOUT
THIS.
I LOVE THAT VEGAS IS CONTINUING
TO SLEEP ON THIS GRIZZLIES TEAM.
THAT ONLY MEANS I GET BETTER
VALUE ON THEM.
THIS IS MY TEAM.
I CAN'T BELIEVE I'M SAYING IT.
THE FACT THAT THE GRIZZLIES ARE
BEHIND THE NUGGETS RIGHT NOW IS
DESPICABLE.
I UNDERSTAND THE NUGGETS HAVE
JOK
JO
JOKIC.
THEY'VE BEEN BLOWING 20,
30-POINT LEADS.
I DON'T THINK THE GRIZZLIES HAVE
GIVEN ANYONE ANY REASON NOT TO
BELIEVE IN THEM.
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU, WE'RE
SCARED TO BELIEVE IN THEM.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE'LL CONTINUE
TO GET THIS GRIZZLIES TEAM AT
THIS GREAT OF VALUE BECAUSE I
THINK THEY'LL CONTINUE TO WIN
GAMES.
THIS IS THE TYPE OF TEAM THAT
WON ARWITHOUT JOHN MORANT.
YOU KNOW I'M ALL IN ON THE
WARRIORS AS WELL, BUT WITH
DRAYMOND GREEN THEY'RE A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT TEAM.
YOU CAN'T GUARANTEE YOUR ENTIRE
TEAM WILL BE HEALTHY IN THE
PLAYOFFS.
THIS GRIZZLY TEAM HAS CONTINUED
TO WIN.
THEY HAVE THAT DEPTH,
COMPETITIVENESS AND EXCITEMENT
TO THEM THAT I THINK WILL CARRY
THEM FAR.
IF YOU SEE ANY POTENTIAL IN THIS
TEAM AT PLUS 4200, YOU MAY NOT
GET THAT VALUE AGAIN.
I THINK IT'S WORTH A SPRINKLE.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> LIV, YOU GOT A FAIR POINT ON
THIS SPRINKLE.
IF YOU GOT MONEY TO BLOW --
>> I STILL LOVE THE WARRIORS.
>> YOU CAN THROW IT ON THE
GRIZZLIES.
IF YOU HAVE MONEY TO BLOW, YOU
KNOW, IF YOU'RE SPRINKLING
MONEY, YOU CAN PUT IT ON THE
GRIZZLIES IF YOU WANT TO.
LET'S -- LET'S COME BACK TO THIS
BOX AND LET'S TALK.
>> REIN IT IN.
>> I JUST THINK THAT THEY'RE A
COUPLE YEARS AWAY.
IN THE PLAYOFFS, WHEN COACHES GO
UP AGAINST EACH OTHER, MATCH-UPS
BECOME A PROBLEM.
ADJUSTMENTS BECOME A PROBLEM.
I DON'T THINK THIS GRIZZLIES
TEAM IS READY THIS YEAR TO
COMPETE IN THE WEST.
MAYBE IN TWO OR THREE YEARS, BUT
RIGHT NOW, I WOULD NOT PUT MY
MONEY ON THIS GRIZZLIES TEAM.
IN FACT, YOU GUYS AT HOME SHOULD
KNOW I'M PUTTING MY MONEY ON
THOSE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS.
WE JUST GOT KLAY BACK.
JAMES WISEMAN IS IN TALKS ABOUT
COMING BACK.
I KNOW THE WARRIORS JUST LOST TO
THIS MEMPHIS GRIZZLY TEAM WITH
NO DRAYMOND.
BUT LIKE I SAID, IN A SERIES
WHERE A TEAM IS FACING EACH
OTHER ON A NIGHT TO NIGHT OR IF
NOT NIGHT TO NIGHT EVERY OTHER
NIGHT BASIS, I JUST SEE THE
ADJUSTMENTS BEING A PROBLEM.
I SEE SUPERSTARS.
THE GRIZZLIES DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
SUPERSTARS, IN MY OPINION, TO
COMPETE IN THE PLAYOFFS.
I'M STAYING WITH THE WARRIORS.
I'VE BEEN ON THE WARRIORS SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR.
MY MAMA ALWAYS TOLD ME IF IT
AIN'T BROKE DON'T FIX IT.
THE WARRIORS AIN'T BROKE THIS
YEAR AND I'M NOT FIXING
ANYTHING.
IT'S NOT ABOUT WHO I'M ROCKING
WITH, IT'S ABOUT WHO THE PEOPLE
ARE ROCKING WITH.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW
GIVING AWAY HOODIES.
I GOT GOAT GARDEN SAYING
WARRIORS IF EVERYBODY IS HEALTHY
WILL WIN.
LANDON IS IN THE COMMENTS.
HE'S ROCKING WITH YOU.
HE SAYS HE CAN SEE THE GRIZZLIES
WINNING THE CHAMPIONSHIP.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, LANDON.
I GOT SCHMIDT YSMITTY BOY 22, H
LUKA SMILING GIF.
I THINK HE'S TALKING ABOUT THEM
DALLAS MAVERICKS POTENTIALLY
WINNING THE CHAMPIONSHIP.
>> WOW.
>> I HAVE ONE MORE IN ME.
ONE MORE IN ME.
XAVIER HOUSE SAYS IT'S TOO EASY,
DUBS IN FIVE AGAINST BROOKLYN.
HE HAS A DRAYMOND GIF GOING.
I'M NOT BEING BIASED ON THE
COMMENTS.
I'M READING THE COMMENTS PEOPLE
ARE TYPING IN.
THE PEOPLE ARE ROCKING WITH THE
WARRIORS.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE WARRIORS.
LIV, ARE YOU ROCKING WITH THE
GRIZZLIES?
IS IT OFFICIAL?
ARE YOU WITH THE GRIZZLIES?
>> I THINK -- I MEAN, I HAVE
GONE MORAN AS MY MVP CHOICE.
I GOT HIM AT PLUS 3200.
I HAVE TO ROCK WITH HIM.
I LOVE THE WARRIORS, I'LL KEEP
RIDING WITH THEM AS WELL.
WARRIORS AND GRIZZLIES.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT BUT DENVER IS
IN THE WEST, BUT THOSE ARE THE
TWO TEAMS I'M ROCKING WITH NOW.
>> I KNOW YOU MENTIONED BEFORE,
JOHN FOR MVP.
I LIKE THAT.
I LIKE THAT AT THIS MOMENT.
I KNOW THIS GREAIZZLIES TEAM MES
SOMETHING TO YOU.
I DON'T DISLIKE YOUR MVP VOTE
FOR JOHN MORAN, BUT YOU
MENTIONED MY WARRIORS AND
WINNING THE CHAMPIONSHIP.
I CAN AGREE WITH YOU.
THE TIME HAS COME.
IT'S THE END OF THE SHOW.
THANK EVERYBODY FOR TAPPING INTO
THE "GROUP CHAT" PRESENTED BY
FAN DUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED
TODTODAY.
THE 3x2 IN THE WARRIORS GAME IS
A LOCK.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE RIDING WITH.
I ALSO THINK THAT THE WARRIORS
WILL WIN THE GAME.
THEY'RE GOING TO BEAT THE BUCKS.
YOU CAN SPRINKLE SOME MONEY ON
THAT.
GET ON FAN DUEL TO GET OUR SAME
GAME PARLAY.
WE'LL BE BACK NEXT THURSDAY
GIVING OUT MORE HOODIES,
JERSEYS, MORE LOCKS.
IF YOU U
YOU WON A HOODIE TOD
WILL DM YOU.
ALONGSIDE LIV MOODS, I'M GREG
IVORY, WE ARE LEAVING THE "GROUP
CHAT."
PEACE.
♪